a court in Italy has handed down life
sentences to 24 people involved in
Operation Condor it was a us-led
offensive back in the 1970s that was
aimed at toppling regimes in six South
American countries the case was
initially opened 20 years ago by
families of the victims kidnappings
torture tens of thousands killed
including through being thrown out of
flying planes the death flights with a
cruel dose of irony the operation was
also given the Arial name Condor for
over a decade the dictatorships of six
Latin American states were cleansing
their left-leaning opposition through
repression and state terror now their
victims have some closure but only some
the executors of Operation Condor
couldn't have excelled the way they did
without help
we have followed events in Argentina
closely we wish the new government well
we wish it will succeed we'll do what we
can to help it succeed
we're aware you are in a difficult
period it is a curious time when
political criminal and terrorist
activities tend to merge without any
clear separation when the standing must
establish Authority in hindsight
establish Authority they did oh by all
means quite literally all six nations
became staunch allies of the US for
which the political purges in Latin
America became a convenient way to
scorch communist idea from its backyard
auguste opener sheikh now a household
name almost synonymous with tyranny
enjoyed financial support from
washington at least through his chief of
intelligence some declassified documents
referred to Operation Condor as a
legitimate counterterrorism action
moreover Henry Kissinger then Secretary
of State was
briefed on the murder operations of
Operation Condor in August 1976 the
operation would last until 1989 and for
all those years the CIA chose not to
step in to prevent the brutal violence
in fact the u.s. kept its finger on the
pulse of Operation Condor aiding at
times with strategic planning Brazil
Argentina Chile Bolivia Paraguay and
Uruguay make up the net they keep in
touch with one another through a u.s.
communication installation in the Panama
Canal Zone which covers all of Latin
America obviously this is the Condor
Network which all of us have heard about
over the last few years the CIA did such
a great job ensuring control of Latin
America through Operation Condor that in
1977 just two years into its official
phase Europe took notes representatives
of West German French and British
intelligence services had visited the
Condor organization Secretariat in
Buenos Aires during the month of
September 1977 in order to discuss
methods for establishment of an anti
subversion organization similar to
Condor due to their view that the
terrorists subversive threats had
reached such dangerous levels in Europe
Kissinger was well aware the CIA knew
all about this State Department knew all
about this and in fact the United States
helped facilitate communications between
the six countries that were involved in
this
people are getting some small measure of
justice but it's much too late many of
the perpetrators have already died you
have to realize this was a vast
operation thousands of thousands of
people involved seven governments
involved at least you have to also
remember that you have the intelligence
services of Britain France and West
Germany also collaborating with these
governments in South America so this was
a global operation to silence critics
silenced reformers this was a horrendous
period in history
you